what was it like creating and recording
that song
brian heard it the day we wrote it and
he was like man let's get in there and
produce again
like we used to back in the day you know
like absolutely man it sounds like a
blast let's do it
the more they kept hearing it the more
we all kept thinking out like
hey why don't y'all just sing on this
thing let's call it a day
[Music]
they really helped bring bring this on
to life for sure ten years later
you know from the success of crews we're
still doing it we're doing it together
and fgl aren't his only famous friends
chase will be heading out on tour with
kane brown
in january how did that all come about
like
have you known came brown for a while i
have known kane for for quite some time
yeah he used to open for me i've opened
for him a few more times
now and then we're obviously doing a
whole tour together so i'm having a good
run here we're having
uh some some good success with these
songs from the album there's
a lot of fun stuff happening right now
with with me and kane so a lot of
success comes together in one arena and
then we fill that place up and have a
big old party
luckily for chase his new best friend
will be joining him
on the road can i see your puppy are you
able to show me
[Music]
absolutely
oh oh my goodness what's his name
name's jack he uh i love jack daniels